CHINA, ISRAEL AND IRAN.
HAVE A LISTEN.
>> I WOULD DESCRIBE OUR
RELATIONS AS ROBUST.
THEY REFLECT HISTORICALLY STRONG
REP THAT HAS CROSSED MANY
ADMINISTRATIONS WITH REPUBLICAN
AND DEMOCRAT GOING BACK NOW WELL
OVER 75 YEARS.
I THINK THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
SEES THAT THE RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE KINGDOM OF SAUDI ARABIA IS
KEY TO THE U.S. INTERESTS AND TO
U.S. PRIORITIES IN THE REGION
AND BEYOND.
AND THEY UNDERSTAND THAT WORKING
WITH THE KINGDOM REQUIRES
WORKING WITH US AND OUR
LEADERSHIP.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS RELATIONSHIP
AT THIS POINT.
THE U.S. IS HEAVILY ENGAGED IN
TRYING TO FIND A SOLUTION TO THE
CONFLICT IN YEMEN.
THEY HAVE MADE YEMEN AN ABSOLUTE
PRIORITY.
TO THAT END, THEY HAVE WORKED
WITH YOU AND THE KINGDOM TO
PRESENT A CEASE-FIRE OFFER TO
THE HOUTHI REBELS, WHICH YOU
YOURSELF HAVE SAID COULD PAVE
THE WAY FOR A POLITICAL
SOLUTION.
HAVE THEY SHOWN ANY SIGNALS THEY
ARE WILLING TO ENGAGE WITH THE
KIN
KINGDOM?
>> SO FAR, WE HAVE SEEN
CONTINUING ATTACKS ACROSS OUR
BOARDERS INCLUDING ATTACKS
AGAINST CIVILIAN TARGETS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE SEE THEM CONTINUING TO
ATTACK.
SO THE INDICATIONS ARE THEY ARE
STILL NOT SERIOUS ABOUT TAKING
THE STEPS THAT ARE NECESSARY TO
MOVE THIS CONFLICT INTO A
POLITICAL PHASE.
NONETHELESS, WE CONTINUE TO PUSH
FORWARD.
WE ARE IN CONTACT WITH THE
HOUTHIS TO TRY TO CONVINCE THEM
THAT PUTTING THE BEST INTEREST
OF YEMEN FIRST IS CRITICAL AND
SEE AND WE SHOULD ALL WORK
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
CONFLICT MOVES NOW TO A
POLITICAL PROCESS.
>> YOU HAVE HIGHLIGHTS THAT
ATTACKS BY THE HOUTHIS CONTINUE
ON THE KINGDOM AND ITS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WOULD YOU TAKE THIS PROPOSED
CEASE-FIRE OFF THE TABLE IF
THOSE ATTACKS CONTINUE?
>> NO, WE ARE COMMITTED TO THE
CEASE-FIRE.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO TAKE THE
CEASE-FIRE OFF THE TABLE.
BUT WE WILL BE DEFENDING
OURSELVES.
WE WILL MAKE SURE YOU PEOPLE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IS PROTECTED.
>> HOUTHIS INSIST THAT ANY DEAL
SHOULD INCLUDE AN AGREEMENT FROM
THE KINGDOM TO LIFT THE BLOCKADE
AND WHAT IS THIS STRATEGIC PORT,
THE U.N. AND WORLD FOOD PROGRAM
SUPPORT ENDING THE BLOCKADE OF A
RECENT INVESTIGATION THAT THEY
HAVE PREVENTED ALL TANKERS FROM
DOCKING AT THE PORT.
AS WE UNDERSTAND IT, FOUR SHIPS
WILL NOW BE ALLOWED TO DOCK, THE
FIRST OF WHICH ARRIVED LAST
WEEK.
AND CAN YOU PROVIDE MORE DETAIL
ON THAT?
>> IN THE LAST 90 DAYS, 67 SHIPS
DOCKED.
AND THERE'S A CONTINUING FLOW OF
GOODS AND SERVICES THROUGH
FORMER BORDER CROSSINGS AND
THERE ARE TWO OTHER PAORTS THAT
ARE ACTIVE.
THERE'S NO BLOCKADE.
THERE'S A MECHANISM WITH THE
UNITED NATIONS AGREE D WITH THE
UNITED NATIONS TO ALLOW SHIPS TO
ENTER.
AND THAT MECHANISM IS CONTINUING
TO BE APPLIED AND WE ASSUME THAT
THE GOVERNMENT WILL CONTINUE TO
GIVE THEIR APPROVAL TO CONTINUE
TO ENTER.
>> WHAT'S THE EXTENT, SIR, OF
IRAN'S SUPPORT FOR THE HOUTHIS
AS FAR AS THE KINGDOM IS
CONCERNED?
>> THE EXTENT IS ARE BROAD AND
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO THE WAR
EFFORT.
THE BALLISTIC MISSILES AND DRONE
TECHNOLOGY IS ENTIRELY OF
IRANIAN ORIGIN, WHICH HAS SO FAR
RESULTED IN WELL OVER 400 DRONES
BEING LAUNCHED ACROSS THE BORDER
AND HITTING THE TARGETS SUCH AS
AIRPORTS AND OTHER CIVILIAN
TARGETS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT WITHOUT THE
SUPPORT OF THE IRAN AND ITS
ADVISERS THAT ARE ON THE GROUND
THE HOUTHIS COULD NOT BE
LAUNCHING THESE ATTACKS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEY WOULD BE
CONSTRAINED IN THEIR ATTEMPTS TO
CONTINUE TO ATTACK OTHER PARTS
OF YEMEN AND TAKE OVER THE
COUNTRY.
>> ALONG WITH ISRAEL AND THE
EMIRATES, SAUDI ARABIA HAS SAID.
WANTS ANY NEW DEAL THAT THE U.S.
MIGHT CUT WITH IRAN TO INCLUDE
CURBS ON ITS BALLISTIC MISSILE
PROGRAM AND ITS SUPPORT OF
MILITIA GROUPS ACROSS THE MIDDLE
EAST, NOT LEAST IN YEMEN.
HOW CONFIDENT ARE YOU THAT IRAN
WOULD AGREE TO THOSE TERMS?
>> WE BELIEVE IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THESE ISSUES BE
ADDRESSED.
WE SEE THESE BALLISTIC MISSILES
TO THE HOUTHIS AND TECHNOLOGY
AND OTHER NON-STATE ACTORS AS A
CRITICAL SOURCE OF INSTABILITY
IN THE REGION.
THE ONLY WAY WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE A PEACEFUL REGION, A SECURE
REGION IS IF WE ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS.
>> WHAT ASSURANCES ARE YOU
GETTING FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND OTHER
EUROPEANS THAT THE KINGDOM WILL
HAVE ITS CONCERNS RAISED DURING
ANY FUTURE NEGOTIATIONS OF THE
JCPOA?
>> THE COUNTRIES MOST AT RISK
ARE THE COUNTRIES IN THE REGION
INCLUDING THE KINGDOM OF SAUDI
ARABIA.
SO IT'S LOGICAL WE SHOULD BE
PARKING LOT OF THE DISCUSSION
AND PART OF THE DIALOGUE.
>> BOTTOM LINE, HOW REALISTIC
THAT YOU CAN BE AT THE SAME
TABLE AS THE IRANIANS ON ANY
JCPOA NEGOTIATIONS?
>> I THINK IT'S ENTIRELY
REALISTIC.
>> DO YOU THINK?
>> WE SEEK FROM IRAN TO STO
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE CAUSING
INSTABILITY IN THE REREGION.
IF IT WERE WILLING TO DO SO,
THAT WOULD OPEN UP THE DOORS TO
NOT JUST THAT, BUT EVEN
CORPORATION.
WE CANNOT HAVE A REPROACH
WITHOUT REDEGREESING THESE VERY,
VERY SEVERE THREATS TO THE
STABILITY AND SECURITY FROM
LEBANON TO SYRIA AND IRAQ AND
YEMEN AS WELL AS ACTIVITIES
WITHIN STATES IN THE REGION
INCLUDING SAUDI ARABIA OF
SUPPLYING TERRORISTS WITH BOMB
MAKING EQUIPMENT.
>> THIS REGION IS A VERY
DIFFERENT PLACE FROM THE LAST
TIME A DEMOCRATIC U.S.
ADMINISTRATION NEGOTIATED WITH
IRAN STARTING IN 2013.
NOT LEAST THIS REGION'S BURGEING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE EAST.
CHINA'S FOREIGN MINISTER PAID AN
OFFICIAL VISIT LAST WEEK TO
DISCUSS THE FUTURE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN YOUR COUNTRIES.
HOW IS THE KINGDOM'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA
EVOLVING?
>> OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA
ALSO GOES BACK SOME DECADES.
IT HAS CONTINUED TO GROW, AS YOU
MADE CLEAR.
ECONOMICALLY, WE ARE STRONGLY
LINKED TO BOTH AS A SUPPLIER,
BUT ALSO AS A CREATIVE PARTNER.
WE THINK CHINA'S ROLE IN THE
REGION ECONOMICALLY IS LIKELY TO
GROW.
WE VALUE THE PARTNERSHIP THAT WE
HAVE WITH CHINA.
WE WORK VERY WELL WITH OUR
CHINESE PARTNERS ON A MULTITUDE
OF ISSUES.
>> SO I WONDER HOW YOU THEN
ASSESS THE TRIP BY THE FOREIGN
MINISTER DAYS AFTER VISITING THE
KINGDOM TO TEHRAN WHERE HE
SIGNED A DEAL TO BUY IRANIAN OIL
AND TO INVEST THEN.
BUT I WONDER HOW DOES FORGING
CLOSER TIES WITH IRAN IMPACT THE
KINGDOMS RELATIONSHIP WITH
CHINA, IF AT ALL?
>> CHINA UNDERSTANDS OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE REGIONAL
ACTIVITY AND ABOUT ITS
DESTABILIZING INFLUENCE ON THE
REGION.
WE BELIEVE THEY UNDERSTAND THOSE
CONCERNS.
THEY HAVE EXPRESSED IT AS MUCH.
THEY ALSO HAVE A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH IRAN.
PERHAPS THEY CAN USE THIS TO
FOCUS ON THE SAME THINGS WE ARE
FOCUSED ON.
>> THEY SIGNALLED THAT A
NORMALIZATION OF TIES WITH SAUDI
ARABIA COULD BE EMINENT SAYING
ON NATIONAL RADIO WE WILL HAVE
DIRECT FLIGHTS FOR MUSLIM,
ISRAELI PILGRIMS TO MECCA.
HOW DO YOU SEE THE KINGDOM'S
RELATIONSHIP EVOLVING SHORT AND
LONG-TERM?
>> THAT NORMALIZATION IN THE
REGION CAN ONLY BE SUCCESSFUL IF
WE ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF THE PAL
ST
PALESTINIANS AND IF WE ARE ABLE
TO DEVELOP A STATE, THAT GIVES
THE PALESTINIANS DIGNITY AND
GIVES THEM THEIR RIGHTS.
IF WE CAN FIND A PATH TOWARDS
THAT, THEN WE CAN SEE A MUCH,
MUCH SAFER REGION